The Joe Rogan Experience there was
another disturbing
um
moment where they were talking about the
rollout of the vaccine and uh Jimmy who
was that guy that was
he was advocating for not rolling it out
to elderly people because elderly people
are predominantly white and that we
should instead do it give it to people
that are essential workers first because
essential workers are more often people
of color and that this will balance
things out like literally say if more
white people die it'll be better because
we'll have more of a balance this came
from the cdc's advisory committee
responsible for deciding who should get
the vaccine yes first or not yes who is
the guy that said it though
there was one per in everybody blew a
[ __ ] gasket because that is really a
crazy the problem is like I don't
remember the name of who said it but all
members of this advisory committee
supported it except for one guy who was
like this is not based on science
because if you look at the statistics
over 80 percent of people dying in this
country from covid are people over the
age of 65. yeah if you want to save
lives you would give it and like 50 of
people being hospitalized over 65 so yes
if you want to save lives if you want to
make it so our icus aren't like at Max
Capacity
then give the vet prioritize the vaccine
based on age instead of occupation there
is a concern though that essential
workers are the ones who spread it more
easily because they have to be in common
I'm glad you mentioned that so it's not
that cut and dry so these essential
workers that are that are getting it
like these folks have to be at work so
they have to be at work they're more
likely to contracted if they get the
vaccine and they're protected from it
then it will spread less likely so
there's there's two things there first
is is who the CDC designates as an
essential worker
um I'll get to that in a second but all
of this is built on the assumption that
this vaccine will prevent the
transmission of the virus which is what
we're hearing from some so-called Health
experts which we're hearing from some in
the media it's not been scientifically
proven I've gone back and looked at the
applications that um and then the data
that was put forward to the FDA to get
approval from Pfizer
and moderna and
these vaccines have been scientifically
established to
largely prevent serious health
complications and death from covid once
you're vaccinated that has been
scientifically established
nowhere in their trials was it
scientifically established that these
vaccines would prevent the transmission
of the virus and so I I see it almost
every day and it's incredibly dangerous
where media outlets and some some people
who are Healthcare professionals
are propagating this
this I mean it's a lie it's not true but
they're basically saying that that well
you know people who have to go and work
in these jobs
um that are essential workers they need
to get vaccinated so they don't spread
it or even you know First Responders we
had we had a local news station in
Hawaii who shared a really emotional
interview from a a first responder
younger woman who had just gotten
vaccinated and she said like finally I
can go and visit my grandmother and not
be worried that I am going to
um give her the virus because I'm taking
care of people who have coveted every
day and what is so dangerous about that
is she got the vaccine if she has then
gone and visited with her grandmother
she could still and Dr fauci's talked
about this and others because this virus
is is lives inside your nasal passage
you can be vaccinated and you can still
pass it on and it could have a a
devastating effect on someone for
example who is elderly uh and who is
vulnerable to this and who has not
gotten the vaccine so anyone who is
saying that well we have to vaccinate
these people or those people based on
their occupation because we don't want
the virus to spread it has not yet it
has not been scientifically established
that the vaccines prevent that and this
is why they're all you know fauci and
these other guys they're like even if
you're vaccinated you have to still wear
the mask you still have to do social
distancing uh because of the potential
for that so I think that's such an
important thing for people to know
especially as people are getting
vaccinated not to have this false sense
of security that just because you've
gotten the vaccine now you can go visit
Grandma in uh the nursing home because
you're not going to expose her
potentially or or put her at risk
but the second issue is is if you
actually go on the CDs I've gone through
all the CDC slides that the advisory
committee put forward on who is a
Frontline essential worker and who's an
essential worker
Healthcare professionals
and First Responders obviously yes they
are so overworked they are over taxed
they should be getting the vaccine right
alongside our elderly over 65. but if
you start getting past them and the
people who are listed as Frontline
essential workers according to the CDC
you're talking about anybody who works
in manufacturing anybody who works at a
grocery store anybody who works at a oh
gosh what were some of the other ones uh
in agriculture in any sector
basically you're talking about
I don't know
half of all working people in Frontline
essential jobs and then you go on to the
essential workers oh teachers and
daycare workers they're included in that
as well and then you go on to essential
workers
people who work at Banks people who work
in the media basically almost everybody
else who is in the workforce as
essential workers
so this goes back to the thing that you
originally said is that part of their
decision-making process was this kind of
Justice component and making decisions
based on who gets the making decisions
about who gets to the vaccine first
not based on who is most likely to die
or get seriously ill but instead based
on occupation
um
it's I I kind of understand why you
would want the people that are forced to
work to get vaccinated before people
that are not forced to work that makes
sense
you know it's just
it's very difficult when you hear that
you're you're you want essential workers
to get vaccinated and they could still
spread it because that seems to me to be
that needs to be really expressed
clearly very clearly it's not being
expected it is because again you let's
say you have that example I mean you
know people over 65 my parents included
like you're you're pretty much stuck at
home yeah because of the day the very
real danger that if you go out and you
get infected you could die yeah
um the danger of
this fact
about how the vaccines have not been
scientifically established to prevent
the transmission of the virus that
that's not being directly told to every
single person who gets it
is a real problem because then they go
home yeah or they go and visit their
parents who they haven't seen for a long
time or their grandparents and could be
carrying the virus and transmitting it
unknowingly because they think like I'm
good now right I'm safe
and and so that has to be part of this I
mean to me there's a direct scientific
correlation based on facts that if you
look at the people who are dying and who
are being hospitalized predominantly
they are people over 65 years old
if we want to reduce those numbers those
are the people who should be prioritized
to get this limited number of vaccines
that we have first Then followed by
younger healthy people I mean it's to me
it's and by doing that you know really
we could reduce the numbers of of covet
related death by about 80 percent
reduce the numbers of coveted related
hospitalizations by I think it's like 48
49 that would have a massive massive
effect on people's lives and and on our
country
yeah well said and uh weird that that's
not being said more often yeah
I've I've been I've been pushing I've
been pushing our both our state
leadership in Hawaii and also
also the Trump Administration so that
the Trump Administration uh just in the
last few days I think it was it January
12th I think the Department of Health
and Human Services did actually adjust
their recommendations
um and they said vaccines need to
urgently go towards people over 65. it
is something that they have strongly
recommended to the states at this point
it's up to the states to choose whether
to implement it or not Texas has Texas
is one of those states that has and
there are a few others but at this point
kind of the lives of our
parents and grandparents are in the
hands of the decisions being made by the
governors and State Health officials in
each state
catch new app new episodes of The Joe
Rogan Experience for free only on
Spotify watch back catalog JRE videos on
Spotify including Clips easily
seamlessly switch between video and
audio experience on Spotify you can
listen to the JRE in the background
while using other apps and can download
episodes to save on data cost all for
free Spotify is absolutely free you
don't have to have a premium account to
watch new JRE episodes you just need to
search for the JRE on your Spotify app
go to Spotify now to get this full
episode of The Joe Rogan Experience